vamos começar de novo
boa tarde gente meu nome a vanda
tenho 25 anos e vou falar pra vocês um
pouquinho das nossas vivências aqui no
estado do espírito santo
a gente ouviu tanta gente falando mas
poucas pessoas falam das coisas que
acontecem realmente aqui produzidas por
quem está do nosso lado
então votar apresentando com meu
companheiro mauro maravilhoso tudo isso
que a gente vive cotidianamente aqui na
cidade de vitória e também compartilha
com outros grupos no estado do espírito
santo eu vim pra vitória com 17 anos é
fiz cursinho meus pais são feirantes é o
que sustenta nossa família até hoje meu
pai tava na feira também o dia de hoje
eu ajudei ele até metade da universidade
quando conseguiu emprego no programa
rede cultura jovem que eu voltar daqui a
pouquinho entrando na universidade eu
tive oportunidade de participar de
projetos de extensão maravilhosas como
ex júnior que é uma empresa de
comunicação e também do bandejão 104.7
que embora não trouxessem bônus aos
currículos dos professores fizeram
completa diferença na vida e fazem dos
alunos que participam porque são uma
possibilidade de escolha e aí a partir
dessa vivência eu entrei em contato com
outras pessoas agentes culturais
principalmente no bandejão e por conta
do redd na época a gente foi contemplado
por um com um projeto
o redd é um programa que se dizia
política pública é executado uma
parceria público privada e acabou
durante o tempo que o governo do estado
não tinha verba para sustentar o
programa
enfim esse programa foi muito importante
na minha vivência de outros porque fez
com que a gente articulasse se articular
se entender como articulador a nível
estadual ea gente conseguiu se conectar
nesse meio conhecer algumas pessoas
começamos a conversar e resolvemos fazer
um festival para ampliar a possibilidade
dos artistas daqui autorais se conectar
e com vocês público e com as pessoas das
comunidades que nós não somos todo o
público da cidade né então a gente
fez esse festival chamado tarde no
bairro ea proposta era ter um lugar para
o artista experience a a sua própria
arte e tem um palco onde ele pudesse
apresentar gratuitamente sem ter que
pagar para se apresentar e tem um lugar
onde o público pudesse acompanhar essas
produções daquilo espírito santo e aí
nesse festival
a gente já fez 24 edições até hoje é a
gente começou a ter algumas dificuldades
para ocupar o espaço público e começou a
se questionar sobre isso
ou será que é só com a gente será que só
a gente faz um festival duas horas da
tarde e ligam por disque silêncio
a partir daí a gente começou a pensar pô
vamos chamar outros artistas para
dialogar para saber se eles têm a mesma
dificuldade
e aí a gente fez um convite aberto uma
lista do rede cultura jovem porque o
redd mapeava alguns coletivos e
disponibilizava esses contatos
a gente chamou todo mundo para conversar
e as pessoas viam e aí a gente fez um
evento chamado revira-volta coletiva em
esse evento reuniu mais de 60 coletivos
37 ações em uma semana
a gente falou de quase morreu a gente
não dormia assim como a gente não dorme
até hoje é muito bom e aí que aconteceu
depois disso a gente não parou mais de
se falar todos nós
todas essas pessoas na grande vitória e
aí a gente começou a entender que esse
não era ocupar o espaço público não é um
problema restrito do assédio coletivo
assim como tantos outros e nossas
vivências coletivos em que começou a
entender que esses grupos ainda depois
do fim do programa eles continuavam
fazendo o que eles queriam na cidade e
transformando as próprias comunidades
a partir desse momento a gente começou a
se reconhecer o outro que a gente não
tinha suporte de ninguém ea gente
continuava fazendo
e aí a gente percebe que essa construção
de narrativa ela é coletiva é autônoma e
ela é conjunta e o que esses grupos
estava fazendo na cidade sem ser
reconhecido por ninguém
eles estavam escrevendo própria história
porque a história deles não é contada
por basicamente ninguém a gente o
acompanha as histórias dessas pessoas
pelas redes sociais e pelos contatos que
a gente fez com elas presencialmente e
esse é um dos trabalhos do assédio
incentivar que mais pessoas circulem
pelas cidades bom reviravolta se tornou
um evento anual ea gente continua
dialogando com os coletivos reconhecendo
eles como a voz das duas das próprias
localidades e é isso que faz a diferença
entender que nós não vamos falar por
ninguém que cada um tem a sua voz e é
dele e dela principalmente mulheres por
direito e ninguém vai tirar isso de nós
a partir desse reconhecimento fomos
dialogar com o poder público
para entender essa ocupação maravilhosa
do espaço e aconteceu
cortaram a nossa voz participamos de
reuniões de conselhos em conjunto e as
duas práticas da juventude continuam
sendo criminalizados
como a gente não pode freqüentar todos
os espaços
a gente não tem direito a circular pelas
cidades skate é criminalizado na praia
de camburi na praça dos namorados e aí
esses grupos maravilhosos com que a
gente tem contato e significam essas
possibilidades dentro das próprias
comunidades lutam por ruas de lazer por
lazer para as crianças
o movimento negro contra homofobia
movimento de mulheres todas as pessoas
existem estão abafadas pelo estado e
pela mídia e essa construção que é
cotidiana e diária não para a gente faz
turno faz contra turno e continua
trabalhando perguntaram mais cedo quinta
2 para trabalhar segunda feira eu vou
trabalhar segunda-feira que a gente
trabalha com isso não só 8 horas são 12
são 14 são 16 porque isso é o nosso
coletivo e quando eu falo coletivo é
montar um grupo que trabalhe uma ação
pode até ser não é um conceito restrito
mas
entende o coletivo como nós nós todos e
aí somos sujeitos in disso tudo que a
gente está construindo se abster deste
debate se abster de ocupar o espaço
público se abster de falar quando você
observa um comentário preconceituoso
desigual racista machista homofóbico é
colaborar para que aquele conteúdo
continua reverberando ainda bem que a
gente está aqui pra colocar nossa voz
para vocês ninguém contaria nossa
história
a gente até tentou dialogar mas a gente
sempre criminalizado
então diante disso é de pegar fiz uma
cola para ver se está tudo bem tá
direitos e redes a gente trabalhe todo
mundo junto isso é consenso entre nós e
esses coletivos gente não está
interessado em competir um com o outro
volta e meia alguém pergunta ah mas como
é que se faz negócio projetos vocês é
como é concorrência entre vocês de fukui
concorrência está interessado em
concorrer o outro agente é justamente
fonte sobre a cidade isso aqui tudo
nosso tudo que a gente quiser pode
acontecer e é sobre isso que a gente
está trabalhando sobre as possibilidades
que a gente constrói em conjunto e daí
convido vocês a entrar nesse universo
também a entender que nós fazemos essas
cidades ea participar desses espaços não
só ir lá assistir um show mas colaborar
mesmo essas pessoas já estão praticando
o diferente a cultura deles não é de
competição no vai de junto à cultura do
mercado a gente tá querendo compartilhar
a gente já faz de um jeito diferente sem
ganhar nada por isso porque isso para
nós não é mais importante embora a gente
entenda que todo mundo precisa viver
precisa ter um salário e 777 ea gente
constrói outras possibilidades para
remunerar e daí os turnos contraturnos
etc
eu falei anteriormente mas caso você
pode passar um e para mim maureen
a gente sempre registra as nossas
atividades porque a gente luta tanto no
meio público
todos os meios por transparência a gente
entende que se as pessoas não tiverem a
possibilidade de olhar diferente mas não
vou olhar aqui vocês estão tendo a
possibilidade de um relatório no nosso
site
de todas as atividades de diversos
coletivos que fazem e acontecem aqui no
estado do espírito santo
estamos em rede e cada um tem a sua
própria rede e vocês também têm então
vamos compartilhar isso a gente está
aqui pra compartilhar e trabalhar juntos
para mudar bom diante disso digo aqui se
eu não tivesse a oportunidade de ter
tido todas as suas vivências
não seria essa pessoa que eu sou hoje ea
escultura para nós é cotidiano
a gente vai continuar trabalhando e digo
isso enquanto mulher e enquanto lésbica
enquanto a pessoa que vai lutar contra
as opressões nesse estado que mais mata
mulheres e mais mata os jovens negros no
brasil então fica o convite pra vocês é
isso
mauro é não é isso
chorar a sanado mas vamos lá
é isso assim né é um chama mauro
sou meu ganho do movimento negro só não
estou na universidade e tenho muito
orgulho em dizer que é a minha vida
política começa dentro do movimento
social e eu vou trazer na memória o
coletivo que eu participava e que talvez
alguns aqui poderiam ter perdido o
contato de conhecer chamava o olho da
rua nem quero um grupo de comunicação e
cultura popular
não era um grupo que estava inserido em
uma ótica de editarem para esses para as
pessoas que elas deveriam fazer o que
elas deveriam produzir sobretudo existe
uma necessidade de falar sobre a sua
própria realidade e parar com a síndrome
william bonner não é falar do morro do
alemão sendo moldada à mão não tem
ninguém no mundo o alemão conseguiu
falar por si só a diferença que o irã
boni está uma estrutura totalmente
aparelhado e possibilitar formar opinião
é em nível macro
e à comunidade não tem essa
possibilidade nesse sentido o olho da
rua ele entendeu que era possível falar
por si só
por entender que a comunidade a qual
houve uma comunidade que produz cultura
né
só que existe uma política de
higienização social que vai dizer o que
é cultura e cultura para quem e como que
a gente está dizendo qual é o mecanismo
que vai se estabelecer para desenvolver
essa tal cultura que vocês estão dizendo
é uma cultura que vai dar lucro alguns
aos empresários é uma cultura que vai
estar adequada um contexto mais
classista mais nobre mas burguês no
conceito do que é a cultura
historicamente tudo aquilo que veio da
comunidade foi marginalizado gente vamos
pegar na história o que quero samba
samba carioca que era o negro malandro
que não sabia que a um sacana que era
que ele estava ali na quebrado parangolê
né
depois pega o funk que se reproduz uma
mesma visão estereotipada que foi que
incentiva a violência que funk é
incentivar isso x e y
mas eu tô avisando que não existe algo
por trás desse contexto que está dado
para além de canalização das ações
culturais à periferia como a gente tem a
capoeira que historicamente foi
modificada e aí me parece que o estado
brasileiro sempre pensou políticas
públicas em retrocesso a vida da
comunidade popular e negra porque eu
preciso colocar dentro dos números
quem é a população que está sendo
negligenciada de ter acesso aos espaços
que dizem ser democráticos e aí eu vou
pegar reverbera na fala do companheiro
anteriormente que trouxe quem é a
população encarcerada quem a população
que não tem acesso à educação de
qualidade quem é a população que não tem
acesso à universidade que é a população
que não tem acesso a um monte de coisa
que estão dizendo ser socialmente
democráticos no acesso ao direito e aí
eu vou fazê lo de novo ao debate de
direito pra quem é é a gente pega essa
foto que encarar é aqui uma comunidade
de vitória a onde é um bairro inclusive
onde o assédio coletivo localizado na
livre que é um espaço que incentiva
coletivamente
outros grupos que não têm perspectivas
de expor a sua ação cultural e outros
espaços porque não existe incentivo não
existe valorização da cultura popular
mas sobretudo existe uma necessidade da
comunidade em saber que existe produção
ali naquele território ea comunidade
reconhece que quando a comunidade
percebe que a coisa mudou a dinâmica ela
se modifica e aí você não tem mais o
cenário de violência como uma única
possibilidade dada ao cotidiano de
homens e mulheres e crianças que vivem
em meio ao causo de erro que é imposto
às comunidades populares que produz a
cada quebrado a gente tem uma
diversidade de produções que não se cabe
dentro do que se disse e cultura hoje
porque é uma cultura que vai de
reverbera uma realidade que está posta e
e aí dentro desse circuito cultural
agente é teve contato de conhecer uma
galera maneira essa foto foi tirada em
terra vermelha que é um dos bairros mais
violentos disso como mais violentos e me
parece que o pano de fundo a comunidade
sofre violência como essa gurizada como
se a dona maria que está aqui sentada
com a criançada na beira da esquina não
tivesse percebendo que a comunidade
produzir não só produz como também usa
dos campos para conseguir garantir
minimamente seu lazer não é uma honra um
artifício de skate um pomposo mas uma
barra de ferro que vai servir como tal é
essa foto pra mim é mais fantástica que
é para reverberar o ponto que a
comunidade necessita de ser reconhecida
enquanto um agente que já produz cultura
muito antes de a gente dizer que eles
precisam produzir alguma coisa essa foto
foi tirada em fechar se vocês perceberam
bem tá bem chuvoso é também uma coisa
meu caótica a galera da comunidade foi
fazer uma atividade onde reuniu um grupo
de jovens que necessitavam de colocar em
prática seus esportes suas habilidades
a comunidade se reuniu em meio à chuva
em meio ao caos não abrir mão de
promover a actividade e que tinha deu
conta e aí percebendo isso a gente
observa
só que enquanto a gente trocando uma
idéia e amanda enquanto a gente fica
pensando em linha até essas pessoas que
já produzem cultura essa galera já está
produzindo e pulado a roleta finalizada
pela roleta porque o direito de ir e vir
não é de todos e essa lógica do todo
mundo democraticamente têm acesso é na
prática o discurso ele não revela essa
prática que dizem por aí
é essa foto foi tirada também lá em
cariacica-sede né por um coletivo também
que se propõe dentro da literatura
desenvolver outras práticas têm o hip
hop tem uma galera que gosta de mandar
rimam break flow para quem anda quebrada
sabe que estou visando e a galera quer
se organizar ea galera que ser
valorizada no sentido de que o estado
abriu mão de criar uma praça de lazer
onde não tem um poste com uma lâmpada
queimada uma árvore seca e um monte de
sacos de lixo jogado pela praça a galera
vai fazer por elas mesmas
e aí a rede que a moda diz é um pouco
isso é trazer para nós coletivos que já
fazem a diferença na sua comunidade
e pra finalizar minha fala pelo tempo
curto
e para mostrar e simplificar que essas
pessoas existem já produzem independente
de não se adequarem aos modelos de
editais e projetos
academicamente construídos que cobram
uma rigidez que é surreal da realidade
da formação educacional da nossa
comunidade negra que está inserida
maioritariamente hoje nas periferias né
vamos lá a gente nem a gente está na
academia consegue fazer a poda desculpa
consegue fazê lo fará às vezes ficava
até 3h da hora eu vou é e aí a minha
fala chamando essa maravilhosa guerreira
para finalizar esse espaço e agradecer
porque eu acho que assim não vamos abrir
mão de falar por nós mesmos
eu acho que você também poderia
finalizar com uma forma que acho que o
homem sempre finaliza os espaços e acho
que esse pode ser finalizada por uma
companheira
a gente queria agradecer de novo tem
mais uma fonte que convidar todo mundo
mas a conhecer esses coletivos
maravilhosa
o que a gente está realmente produzindo
e assim não acredita em vitória não tem
nada
não acredito em que ganhou todos somos
nós que fazemos às vezes a gente nem
está com um problema sim de não está
fazendo nada então circulem e conheçam
as pessoas troquem referências todo
mundo tem algo pra compartilhar com
todos nós ea gente precisa apresentar
essas possibilidades não pra camuflar as
desigualdades mas para evidenciar que
existem diferenças e que a gente está
aqui pra fazer esse mundo um pouquinho
mais justo
é isso aí adeus